noir désir fer de lance du rock français
sort dans 2 jours sans septième album le
groupe originaire de bordeaux a débuté
il ya 20 ans et ses fans attendent avec
impatience les nouvelles productions de
ce groupe qui se montrent très rarement
à la télé olivier les nougats christ au
final entre ciel et mer
le retour sur terre de noir désir
après cinq ans de silence le groupe
phare du rock français revient apaisé on
n'est pas le groupe de rock en france je
supporte pas cette définition
la douce révolution des girondins qu'ils
sont maîtres de leur temps il faut c'est
d'un son qui leur confère une place à
part le chanteur avait failli perdre sa
voix à force de crier sa rage de faire
rugir les orages place aux éclaircies
la partition est aujourd'hui plus calme
mais toujours incisif
ça prend du temps pour éviter les pur
réflexe de
reproduction de ce qu'on sait déjà faire
donc il s'agit d'aller chercher en soi
d'autres paysages
enfin ils sont là mais ils sont enfouis
donc il faut les faire sortir
embarquement pour de nouveaux rivages
nos plages de la méditerranée premières
images du nouveau clip de noir désir
fait peur
des chansons qui descendait à rêves
l'utopie d'une société plus humaine qui
dénonce la guerre économique
les dégâts collatéraux le même
vocabulaire que celui de la guerre du
golfe les dégâts collatéraux dans le
capitalisme sauvage
c'est le genre de truc qu'on ne regarde
pas et nous c'est justement ce qui nous
ce qu'ils nous parlent le plus
la jubilation d'une famille une bande de
copains qui distille avec poésie
une touche de magie noire
voyage à travers les mots